Millennials moving into home ownership
in growing numbers Brian will spoke to a
millennial couple who just recently
bought a home and looks how they did it
why Millennials can now afford it
yeah as you go through it just kind of
pretty open floor plan 28 year old Scott
Barr and his wife are both Millennials
and just bought this home last year we
got a meeting with a realtor just to see
what the market looked like and at the
time the house prices weren't too
inflated the rates were still pretty
decent for many Millennials
homeownership may seem Out Of Reach I
spoke to a realtor today who says there
are options to help you get a home we
sit down we talk with you we find out
what your needs are we make sure you get
qualified you know if you have to work
on credit we have we get you qualified
with the right person so
the most important thing is first to
reach out to your local realtor as for
Barr it just made sense to buy a home
after going through their options it
made more financial sense for us to just
buy the house as opposed to rent long
term Millennials like him are moving
into Home Ownership thanks to higher
incomes and help from their parents a
Lending Tree survey found 60 percent of
millennial home buyers had help with
their down payment compared to previous
generations it took Millennials longer
to save up enough to afford their first
home the median age of home ownership
for them is 34. it's good news for
realtors like Mary Perry there are 50 in
the market now which is great like half
Millennials all own homes